[موسيقى]
الجمعيه الجيوفيزيائيه الامريكيه وهي اكبر
الجمعيات العلميه المتخصصه في فهم
الزلازل والكوارث الطبيعيه حسمت هذا
النقاش انه لا يمكن استخدام عمليه اصطفاف
الكواكب
لتفسير عمليه وقوع الزلازل هناك فارق كبير
بين المنطق البسيط ان هو انه اصطفاف
الكواكب بيزيد من عمليه الجذب على
القشره الخارجيه لكوكب الارض وما بين
القوه الموجوده في باطن كوكب الارض التي
تعادل اضعاف هذه القوه فبالتالي وضع
الاتنين في نفس التكافؤ هو غير صحيح
وتصادف حدوث هذه الاحداث مع عمليه
الاصطفاف هو مجرد مصادفه وليس سببا علميا
بالزلازل التي نشاهدها
[موسيقى]
اكتر مناطق تتاثر بالزلازل في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط هي بالتاكيد منطقه الشام ام منطقه
كلهم وهو في في
الحدود ما بين سوريا وتركيا ولكن ايضا في
الجزائر والمغرب
واجزاء من مصر واجزاء من اليمن نقدر نقول
اللي هو لا يوجد مكان في العالم العربي
بعيد عن تحركات الزلازل سواء كانت هذه
الحركه للزلازل بشكل يعني متزايد سنويا او
في فترات متباعده مثل مثلا ما هو الحل في
مصر ومنطقه شبه الجزيره العربيه
[موسيقى]
لا حقيقه ابدا لربط بين عمليات المد
والجزر نقدر لغير اعتياديه اللي حصلت في
الفتره اللي فاتت والزلزال الموجود في
تركيا بكل اختصار حركه المد والجذب تتغير
المعدلات اللي فيها وتؤثر فيها تحركات
القمر ولكن ايضا تؤثر فيها تحركات الرياح
وبعض عوامل مثل الضغط الجوي فما صار في
الفتره اللي فاتت من عمليه الجذر العالي
او المنخفض التي رايناها في عده اماكن هو
بكل اختصار ضعف حركه الرياح اللي ادت الى
زياده معدلات الجزر التي نراها وهو ما
يفسر الخاله الجويه الممتازه في كل الصور
التي تمت لهذه عمليه الجزم
[موسيقى]
اولا علينا ان نفهم عمليه
دراسه الزلازل ورصد الزلازل وهي عمليتين
مختلفتين من بعض بشكل عام هناك سؤال دايما
هل نستطيع ان نتنبا بالكوارث الطبيعيه
والاجابه في بعض الحين نعم في بعض الحين
لا بتفرق حسب الكارثه الطبيعيه اللي
بنتكلم عنها فلننظر مثلا في مثال الزلازل
هناك مرحله اولى وهي الدراسه هذه الزلازل
هي هي فهم فيزياء تحرك الالواح واحتكاكها
ببعضها البعض وامكانيه عمليه وقوع
قوه الزلازل نتيجه عمليات تحرك هذه
الالواح هذا ما يسمى بالدراسه
السلاسل اما عمليه
رصد الزلازل فهي البحث عن متغيرات صغيره
جدا تشير الى احتماليه وقوع زلزال في
الفتره القادمه وهذه العمليه عمليه معقده
وليست عمليه توقعات هي عمليه ارصاد اذا لا
يمكن لشخص بدون هذه الارصاد بمجرد النظر
للحركه الكواكب والاقمار وغيره ان يفهم او
يتنبا بوقوع زلزال او بوقوع كارثه طبيعيه
في غياب اجهزه رصد وبعد عمليه الدراسه
والرست تاتي عمليه ايجاد الحلول للوقايه
من اثار الكوارث الطبيعيه وهذه العمليه
مبنيه على الارصاد ومبنيه على فهم هذه
الكوارث ما يحدث مع الاسف في عالمنا
العربي في اكثر من مكان ان المسؤولين يقول
انا عايز حل انا عايز حلول ويبدو في هذا
كانه شخص راسين وعملي ولكنه في النهايه
هذا غير صحيح لا يمكن ان نحل مشكله لا
نفهمها وهذا ما يفسر ارتفاع اعداد الضحايا
ليس فقط نتيجه لقوه الزلزال ولكنه نتيجه
لغياب هذه الدراسات وغياب الارصاد
وبالتالي غياب المعايير الوقايه من هذه
الكوارث الطبيعيه
[موسيقى]
اولا علينا ان نعرف ان الكوارث الطبيعيه
والتغيرات المناخيه والبيئيه لكوكب الارض
هي حقيقه علميه ثابته ونراها في الكوكب
الذي نعيش فيه وكواكب المجموعه الشمسيه
الاخرى اذا ما يحدث في في الكوكب الذي
نعيش عليه ليس مفاجاه وليس نهايه للكون
وليس كل هذا هو المفروض يكون نهايه لعمليه
الاستخفاف بدراسات التغيرات التي يمر بها
الكوكب الذي نعيش عليه
في في موقف يحضرني انا لا انسى ابدا ان
انا كنت في مهمه علميه في الصحراء الغربيه
في سنه 2004
في مصر
وحضرنا بمجموعه من الاجهزه العلميه وهي
نماذج تحاكي
الروبوت الذي ينزل على سطح المريخ
ووصلت الاجهزه وفضلت محبوسه في المطار في
منطقه الجمارك الافريقي للافراج الجمركي
وتاخرت هذه
الاجهزه فبعد عشره ايام الانتظار نصحوني
ان انا اقابل رئيس
يعني واحد في فراش اللي هو بيقدم الشاي
والقهوه قال لي انا هدخلك رئيس الجمرك
وتشرح له القصه بتاعتك وهو ده صاحب الحل
الوحيد وفعلا فهذا الرجل مشكور يعني دخلني
معاه فقال لي بتتكلم معه باختصار ان هو ما
بيحبش يضيع وقته عشر ثواني بالكثير قوي
قلت له ماشي فدخلت معاه واول ما قابلته
قلت له يا فندم انا اسمي عصام حقي وبشتغل
في وكاله ناسا وده البادج بتاعي اهو وعندي
مركبتين فضاء واقفين عند حضرتك في الجم رك
وعايزين نطلعها
رئيس الجمرك بص كده لسعر الفراشه ايه
الراجل المجنون ده وكان فعلا المركبتين
دول كانوا نموذجين مركبتين الفضاء
كانوا واقفين في الجمرك ولكن لانه ما كانش
في اي واسطه وما كانش اي اتصال ما طلعوش
بعدها بمده واتنشر الخبر في جريده بروز
اليوسف ساعتها نشرت خبر في صفحه اولى
بالكبير الجمارك لا تعرف ناسا فبس الشيء
المضحك اللي هنا ان احنا على قد ما بنسمع
من الاهتمام بالعلوم الفضاء وعدنا بنسمع
بعلماء في الخارج ولكن وقت ما تيجي تعمل
في ابحاث بتكتشف ان الشيء ده مختلف تماما
عن ده ففي حياه الشخصيه يعني انك انت تعمل
في عالم الفضاء ناس بتقول يعني انت سايب
كل المشاكل على كوكب الارض وبتشتغل على
الفضاء ايه الرفاهيه دي يعني انت انسان
مرفه انت بتشتغل فيه كواكب اخرى لما تحل
مشاكلنا بس انا بحب اوضح حاجه واحده ان
عملي في اكتشاف كوكب المريخ هي الوظيفه
الوحيده اللي انا قدمت عليها في حياتي
وقبلت فيها لان المكان الوحيد اللي مكنش
فيه واسطه هو كوكب اخر بالنسبه للمواطن
العربي يعني
[موسيقى]